oh man i love you
oh thank you man
my nickname is baby gorilla baby gorilla
that's good for the self-esteem yeah
it's always dudes who yell out my name
it's never chicks right
even when they say like i love you yeah
and people say art did you have a lot of
sex with being on the howard stern show
and i'm always like if i was willing to
have sex with plumbers i'd be like
i've been like a young warren beatty
yeah i know but uh i don't know what
happened was
uh you're gonna find this surprising but
i'm a bit disheveled when i traveled i i
don't i noticed even your hair you came
out
and you look like grandpa munster just
woke up from a nap
it's going all over the place
i'm sorry i'm sorry i look like danny
bonaducci's
all right ladies i'm gonna start busting
chops either way yeah yeah i got it
exactly the david beckham brothers
this is a comedy portion of the show
yeah uh
yeah you know okay well i'm on a second
leg of a uh
the road i went to san francisco to do
gigs now i'm here and i have to do
laundry at the hotel and those crazy
things they make you fill out yes yeah
i'll make you fill out those things to
do laundry and these don't your socks
yeah how many socks how many and you're
filling it out you're like dude
you know it's like i'm taking the sats
again
and uh dude i just want to wash my socks
and i'm not trying to get into notre
dame
i can't help but notice you have this uh
super bowl uh
yeah were you excited by this year's
super bowl were you were you having a
patriots fan well no i was excited
because i had the patriots in the over
yeah i won
i won five grand yeah uh but
you weren't emotionally invested look i
don't know how seahawks fans dealt with
that guys first of all conan
congratulations thank you i know you're
a patch guy yeah i appreciate it uh yeah
you know
give me something here yeah you're a red
sox guy red sox just got that panda guy
from the san francisco giants now you
have david ortiz and panda yeah
i mean
talk about baseball you do not have to
be in shape for man the red sox are the
best team in the world and they have a
couple of guys who are their stars who
look like ceelo green
[Laughter]
you have look at that guy
the last time that guy did a sit-up yeah
but uh he hits the baseball you hit you
play you hit your play right uh and uh
you know so i congrat but you gotta
admit that last call in the super bowl
man yes belichick throwing the ball he
had five he had three chances
three chances to run the ball a yard
no i'm sorry carol
p carroll had three chances to run the
baller yard okay to get the biggest
prize in sports maybe in on the planet i
mean it's royalty
three tries with the best short yardage
running back of all time just hand it to
him and instead he threw it to him and i
tried to think for weeks as a comic what
is the only analogy
a seattle seahawks
seahawks fan can somehow justify in
their head right and here's what i came
up with this is as close as i can think
say someone tells you you want to you 20
120 million dollars in the lottery okay
and the only way you can recover it is
to go to an atm machine and get it and
they give the atm card and on your way
to the atm machine to get to 20 million
bucks
you get a foot
before the atm machine when you stop
you're one foot away yeah okay
instead of putting the card in
you throw the card
[Applause]
and then
your worst enemy
runs by picks up the car
puts it in and gets to ten
and then just starts making out with rob
gronkowski
right and then you go back to your car
and and marshawn lynch is sitting in
your passenger seat and you tell them
the story and he goes why just let me do
it man
i've done it
that's a great analogy